aaron simpson here taking a look at in
certainties new update maltov spring the
two new maps are live buries and revolt
buries is a outdoor desert map with some
low buildings revolt is a seaside town
with some close quarters battles that
take place in the interiors and then
open streets what you see me playing
right now is a cooperative mission on
buries I really like the way that
insurgency handles co-op it's a lot like
the onslaught mode from bad company 2
dai is very intelligent they'll build up
a base of fire on your team and then
start trying to flank you if you get
killed you're out until your team takes
the next objective or guys trying and
then you have to start the round over
again I really like insurgency there's
no unlock tree it's just pure combat
you're just playing for the fun of it
and yes there are molotovs in the
molotov spring update maltov spring also
adds some new modes infiltrate occupy
flashpoint and vendetta and new crop and
emissions for all maps you'll also find
some new scopes and attachments in here
overall I really like insurgency it
feels to me like ARMA with a better
control scheme if you already bought
insurgency it's free so it's a
no-brainer if not uncertainty can be
purchased on Steam enjoy the gameplay
hey cover me I'm reloading
you